[Music]
so sometimes
just knowing your inputs and your
outputs is not enough because you know
they can hide kind of the middle
interactions of your reactives
i know this is a smaller app but it
tries to get across the point of we can
export these inner reactive values it's
not just your inputs and outputs you can
export these inner reactives
so
i'm interested in this first letter i
know the phrasing of the first letter in
your name is
b or whatever the first part of your
name is
but
i want to actually just have that letter
as a value that i can test against
so
uh we have our recording
and i'm going to adjust this copy and
adjust this recording
and i'm going to do
some alterations for it so we can export
those test values so let's say
uh let's call a new test so export test
values
and
we'll say export values just for fun
in this case the app is not going to be
doing anything specific with screenshots
or the app itself is not dependent on
the width so i'm going to remove the
height and width restriction and just
use the defaults
i'm going to set the inputs of name
barrett and i'm going to click greet
and one thing we could do here is
just get
value and we want to say
output equals
first letter
and this should have if i'm running the
application this should be this phrase
so we can just copy it
and i'm gonna say first
letter
and uh not just the first letter but the
first letter phrase
and we'll say expect equal
to uh first
letter
phrase
and
the whole like my first letter in my
name
is b
okay
so let's
for now i'm just going to comment that
earlier test
we're going to just run all the tests
right here
[Music]
so this will start a new app driver
uh given the application it's just
called export values to have it as a
name
i set the name
to barrett i then click greet and then i
get the value of the output first letter
but we should just actually see what
this is like in the console just because
it's fun to see this interactively
because i'm just taking a guess that
first letter phrase is this
first letter phrase
it does equal
the first letter your name is b
so this expect equal passed
and we saw that pass
a little warning here of deleting unused
screenshots
or snapshots is uh of these that is
because i commented this test so test
that is like those tests don't exist
anymore so we shall delete them and
that's that's okay that's uh you know if
i undo this and rerun it that those
snapshots will come right back so
this is how we can get the whole phrase
but the thing i was interested in
was the letter b
and this is where it becomes very neat
and that we can export those values so
there's a method under shiny called
export test values
and export test values is a key to
reactive expression
set of arguments
that it can take so in here i could say
first
letter uh does you know i could just
call it you know first it doesn't really
matter it's my own custom key but i'm
just gonna for consistency i'm gonna
just call it first letter
and this will equal the reactive
equal to the output of the reactive
expression
so the reactive expression that i'm
executing is first
letter and then since first letter is a
reactive i need to execute it at the end
okay so
a lot of things there but
what
does that give us if we were to
uh since the app has
you know been updated we need to rerun
our app so i will kill the old one app
stop
and then let's actually just
get us back into the state that we are
at so let's make a new app driver
let's call set inputs let's click
and let's just look at the values that
we can that are currently in the app
with git values so this will return all
the import
or sorry input output and exported
values we just added a
first letter exported value
yay
so we have our inputs that we remember
we have input greet and input name
we have our outputs of first letter and
greeting and then we have export this
first letter and now we have access to
this reactive value so it doesn't need
to be outputted we can just use an
exported value
so for this one
we can also say a app dollar get value
of export equals
first
letter um
and
here on 15 the skip value of output as
first letter
is retrieving output first letter
where i'm more interested in export
first letter so i will say export of
first letter
and we'll do expect equal
to
b
and if i run this
it passes
just for proof if i change it to a j and
i run it it'll say up
error found actual is b but you expected
j
so you do want b so i'll change it back
and run it just to confirm great we're
good
uh and then i will run all the tests
because you know it's unit tests we
should be able to run these
all the time quickly
great now we have two
checks passed awesome
[Music]